Grabbing things in space is tricky.
Unless things are designed to fit together…
...it can a bit hard to latch on.
With no atmosphere, suction is out.
And sticky adhesives are rendered useless
by extreme cold and degrading radiation.
So scientists looked to nature for ideas,
finding inspiration in the toes of geckos
-- who easily scramble up smooth surfaces.
The key to this remarkable ability are
microscopic hairs strategically arranged
on a gecko’s feet.
When pressed, these hairs flatten out against a surface,
and tiny forces of molecular attraction
add up across the may points of contact -
- creating instant grip.
Scientists tried to mimic this technique
by creating tiny wedges
that act similarly to these hairs.
Forces that smoosh the wedges
into a surface create grip,
while tangential forces peel the material away.
By adding this material to robotic contraptions,
scientists could pick up and release objects remotely...
...and even direct a robot to walk across a wall.
Scientists tested the grippers
on a minimal friction platform
to show that robots in zero gravity
should be able to grasp objects like solar panels
instead of simply pushing them away.
And during the nose-dive induced weightlessness
of NASA’s famous zero gravity aircraft,
training astronauts used them to play catch
with both flat and curved objects.
The researchers also sent miniature grippers into space
where they stuck to the walls of the ISS.
Developing such a tool could be important
for many space projects,
from clearing out floating debris
orbiting our planet,
to performing dangerous tasks with robots,
so that astronauts can stay safe.